foreign  for Ten Thousand Years the Imperium has  dominated the Galaxy  there is only War  every human soul from the most Highborn  Lord to the most basic assertive  to the service of the god emperor of  mankind  the imperium's battlefleets and armies  from the conscripted soldiers of the  Astra militarum  to the elite Space Marines of the  adeptice of statins  keep Humanity safe from Alien threats  and Cosmic Horrors Beyond imagine  but there is another War it is the one  in which I serve  our war is not one of battlefields and  Fleet engagements  it is waged by the dedicated agents of  the Imperial Inquisition  it is fought in the cities and hives of  the Imperium  in the back streets and the Forgotten  sub-levels  in hyped cities like tertion  yes  if we fail  the Imperium Falls with us